[Applause]
[Music]
rihanna became the
ultimate birthday gift for one lucky fan
i hope that we could really pull this
off the pop star was out to dinner
recently and nearby
was a group of friends out celebrating a
birthday
happy birthday
and then just as the dessert arrives and
her friends began
singing happy birthday there was riri
happy birthday happy birthday
[Applause]
the friend behind it all broke down how
this magical moment
came to be so we're at dinner right
and we see her she's sitting across from
us she reveals it all started with
a much more modest favor from the mega
star but
rihanna said she could do her one better
so then i walked up to her table and i
was like oh it's my best friend's
birthday it would mean the world if you
could you know go over there and say
happy birthday to her or take a picture
with her
so she was like go back to the table and
say i said no
but when the cake comes out i'm gonna
walk up to the table and surprise her
in the video rihanna even takes a moment
to joke about the initial request
i told her you said no let's take a
picture now
so that's literally exactly what she did
she was so freaking nice about it
as soon as the cake was coming to the
table she followed
our waitress right and then she came and
took the pictures with us she was so
friendly she's like you guys are so
beautiful
but this might be the best revelation
from the whole night
and she smells so freaking good
and that's how we met rihanna and now
the video is all over
rihanna actually has her own signature
line of fragrances
and we have a pretty solid guess which
perfume she had on that night
girls night out riri hands down this is
all about
girls and feeling that
that femininity and confidence when you
go out you feel flirty
you feel fun and you feel sassy i mean
all those things are
the ingredients that make me and this is
why i called it riri it's a very
girly flirty fragrance and rihanna's
creative good deed
might be an extension of her quarantine
mindset
i just want to figure out a solution
i don't want to stay stuck on the
problem
she told et in september how the
pandemic has given her a new perspective
on staying happy how do you continue to
keep yourself inspired and motivated
during times like these
i just try to think about what i really
love to do like what truly makes me
happy and
it's really the littlest things so
the what do you do about it aspect has
come into
uh full play during this quarantine
and it's it's helped a lot and it's
forced me to figure things out
and get creative and clever about it
whether it's
loving to perform design lingerie
make perfume start a cosmetics line
give back to the world or simply
surprise a lucky fan on her birthday
rihanna takes the cake
[Music]
you